Как перестать ходить по кругу и
перестать совершать одни и те же ошибки?
Это видео для тех, кого не устраивает
э-э то, как они живут, в каких условиях
они живут, несмотря на то, что они
стремятся к целям, что-то делают, но
ничего в их жизни не происходит, и то,
что с ними происходит, их не устраивает.
Давайте разбираться с этим и поговорим
об этом. Обязательно ставьте лайк под
этим видео и внимательно слушайте
дальше. Итак, для того, чтобы перестать
ходить по кругу, а я вам сегодня дам три
лайфхака. что вам нужно делать, чтобы
перестать ходить по этому заколдованному
кругу и чтобы, наконец-то, вырваться из
этой суеты. Первое, что я лично в своей
жизни очень часто, я бы сказал, не
часто, а постоянно в своей жизни
применяю, это не совершать повторяемых
ошибок или повторных ошибок. Это правило
вроде банальное, но у вас у всех
наверняка возникает сразу же вопрос:
легко сказать: "А как это сделать?" Так
вот, я вам даю лайфхак, как я это делаю.
Когда я совершаю какую-либо ошибку, я
обязательно сразу же прописываю
алгоритм. Алгоритм - это как вот такой
храповый механизм. Вы знаете, такой
механизм, когда как трещётка, так тык
тык тык-тык-тык. Он получается в эту
сторону двигается, а назад не двигается.
Так вот, алгоритм - это вот такой
механизм, который позволяет вам не
совершать одну и ту же ошибку повторно.
Поэтому, когда вы совершаете какую-либо
ошибку, обязательно делайте рефлексию,
то есть анализируйте, почему она
произошла. Анализируйте и сразу же
прописывайте, что вам нужно в следующий
раз делать, чтобы эта ошибка не
повторилась. Приведу сразу же простой
пример. Однажды на меня обиделся очень
близкий мне человек, потому что когда я
выступал, я благодарил вокруг всех и
забыл упомянуть его. Вы знаете, я сам не
очень эмпатичный человек, и со мной это
периодически случается. И так как это
было, по-моему, второй или третий раз, я
понял, что это какой-то определённый
паттерн. Поэтому, что я сделал? Я
составил себе алгоритм порядок
благодарения. То есть, кого я благодарю
в первую очередь, во вторую очередь, в
третью, в четвёртую, в пятую и так
далее. И каждый раз, когда мне
предстоит, а, держать какую-то речь,
вот, например, а-а, я написал книгу, мне
говорят: "Вот выступите". Понятно? Такое
выступление подразумевает, а,
благодарение аэ других людей, Всевышнего
и так далее. Я сразу же перед такой
речью просто одним глазом смотрю на этот
алгоритм, и у меня в голове картинка, я
знаю, что говорить, как говорить, в
какой последовательности и так далее. И
этот алгоритм спас и спасает меня во
многих случаях. И таких алгоритмов у
меня на самом деле очень много и на
многие случаи жизни. И вообще я считаю
так: алгоритмы они сами по себе ресурс.
Это сам по себе ресурс, который вас
оберегает от ошибок, от повторных
ошибок. И я часто говорю, что а
бизнесмены должны быть как гусеницы,
которая вот так ползёт вперёд. пожирает
события и ошибки, а из задницы,
извиняюсь за выражение, вместо паутинки
у него вылезают алгоритмы. И эти
алгоритмы в виде паутинки не позволяют
этой гусенице потом упасть. Вы должны
представить, что что вы пожираете. Вы
пожираете события, которые с вами
происходят, и вы пожираете
ошибки как последствия своих каких-то
неправильных действий. Вы должны это
пожирать и выдавать алгоритмы. И
благодаря этим алгоритмам,
а вы не будете совершать повторных
ошибок, и это сильно ускорит ваше
движение вперёд к вашей цели. Переходим
ко второму лайфхаку. Для того, чтобы не
крутиться как белка в колесе, вам нужно
не делать одних и те же действий, ожидая
при этом разный результат. Ещё,
а, по-моему, Эйнштейн это говорил.
Безумие - это когда человек совершает
одни и те же действия и при этом ожидает
разный результат. Так вот, к сожалению,
большинство людей, по сути, из-за того,
что их мозг или внимание полностью
захвачена социальными сетями и они живут
неосознанной жизнью, то, по сути, они
живут как безумцы. Они совершают одни и
те же действия, каждый день ходят на
одну и ту же работу. Одними и теми же
путями делают эту работу так же, как
вчера, не приносят ничего нового,
общаются с одними и теми же людьми.
Дорогие мои, откуда в вашей жизни тогда
будут изменения? Почему вы тогда
считаете, что вы достойны того, чтобы
жить другой жизнью? Хорошо, по-моему,
сказала Како Шанель, которая сказала:
"Если вы хотите жить, как а другие не
могут, вы должны делать то, что другие
не хотят". И это относится как раз к
этому второму правилу. Поэтому, если вы
хотите, чтобы в вашей жизни случилось
что-то хорошее, другое, перестаньте
делать одни и те же действия. Либо
начните делать что-то другое, либо
делайте то же самое, но по-другому, и вы
увидите, что результаты будут другие.
Третий лайфхак. Для того, чтобы выйти из
замкнутого круга, из этого беличго
колеса, в котором, которое нас всех
засасывает, нужно иметь чёткую цель и
измеримые метрики прогресса движения к
ней. То есть у вас должна быть цель и
измеримые метрики, которые показывают,
вы движетесь, приближаетесь к своей цели
или не приближайтесь. Потому что
проблема большинства людей в том, что у
них есть цели, но нету метрики,
показывающие,
насколько они приближаются к своей цели.
В результате, по сути, их цель является
не целью, их цель является просто
мечтой. А мечта она на то и мечта, что
она никогда не осуществляется, пока она
не перерождается в цель. Поэтому третий
лайфхак. Если вы хотите вырваться из
этого порочного круга ежедневной суеты,
превращайте свои мечты в цели с
конкретными измеримыми метриками,
показывающие прогресс продвижения к ней.
Если вы примените в своей жизни хотя бы
три этих лайфхака, я уверен, вы покинете
эту суету и белечее колесо, и в вашей
жизни начнут происходить чудесные
изменения. Очень часто бывает такая
ситуация, что многие люди утверждают,
что они что-то хотят и что у них есть
какие-то цели, и они целый день
работают, но ничего не происходит. Здесь
я дам вам такой бонусный дополнительный
лайфхак. Для этого, ребята, делайте
ежедневно рефлексию. Звучит сложно, но
что такое рефлексия? Вы просто берёте 15
минут, 10 минут в конце дня и
спрашиваете, задаёте себе только один
вопрос: что я сегодня сделал?
Какое действие, которое приближает меня
к моей цели? Просто задайте себе этот
вопрос. И утром, когда вы идёте на
работу или когда просыпаетесь, задайте
себе вопрос: "Что я сегодня сделаю,
которая хотя бы на шаг приблизит меня к
моей цели?" Если вы будете задавать
ежедневно два этих вопроса, вы поймёте,
действительно ли вы хотите идти к своей
цели или эта цель вас не драйвит. Если
эта цель вас не драйвит, не зажигает, не
мотивирует, будьте уверены, эта цель
навязана вам извне. Значит, эта цель не
ваша. А для того, чтобы понять, какая
цель ваша, для этого нужно вам побыть в
одиночестве и знать определённые
алгоритмы, ну, которыми я часто делюсь в
своём Telegram-канале. Переходите по
ссылке, которую я оставляю здесь внизу.
И у меня к вам большая просьба. Напишите
в комментариях ваши случаи, когда вы
крутились как белка в колесе и не могли
и найти выход из этого круга и благодаря
чему вам удалось из него вылезти. Либо
если вы до сих пор находитесь в такой
ситуации, напишите после этого видео,
пришло ли у вас понимание, как вырваться
из этого круга и что вы будете для этого
делать. Бывают люди, которые всё время
за чем-то гоняются, за новыми знаниями,
занимаются саморазвитием, а, суетятся,
хотя у них в жизни всё благополучно и
нормально. Вы знаете, почему это
происходит? А это синдром называется
FOMO. Это Fear of Missing out. С
английского переводится как страх
упустить что-то. Обычно этот страх
психологически вызывается социальными
сетями, где нам всем демонстрируется
успешный успех. И такое складывается
ощущение, что все развиваются, все
куда-то идут, у всех что-то что-то
получается. Вот только я отстаю от
жизни. На самом деле это часто
происходит, э, потому что человек, а,
мало синхронизируется с собой и идёт на
поводу, э, у социальных сетей, блогеров
и так далее. Рекомендую такому человеку
побольше быть самим собой и чаще
разговаривать со своим внутренним
мечтателем, со своим сердцем, со
Всевышнем и думать о том, как о нём
думают люди и как они его воспринимают.
Поэтому в таких случаях больше побудьте
оставайтесь в одиночестве и думайте над
своей жизнью. Я уверен, вы приблизитесь
к своим истинным целям, и это приведёт
вас к большему успокоению и
удовлетворению тем, что у вас есть. M.